what we're going to prove in this video
it's a couple of fairly straightforward
uh parallelogram related proofs and this
first one we're going to say hey if we
have this parallelogram a b c d let's
prove that the opposite sides have the
same length so prove that a b is equal
to dc and that a d is equal to bc so let
me draw a diagonal here so i'm going to
draw a diagonal
and this diagonal depending on how you
view it is intersecting two sets of
parallel lines so you could also
consider it to be a transversal actually
let me draw it a little bit neater than
that i can do a better job
so nope that's not any better
that is about as good as i can do
so if we look if we view db this
diagonal db we can view it as a
transversal for the parallel lines a b
and d c and if you view it that way you
can pick out that angle abd
is going to be congruent so angle abd
that's that angle right there it's going
to be congruent to angle bdc
because they're alternate interior
angles you have a transversal parallel
lines so we know that angle a
b d
is going to be congruent to angle
b
dc
angle bdc
now you could also view this diagonal db
you could view as a transversal of these
two parallel lines of the other two the
other pair of parallel lines a d and b c
and if you look at it that way then you
immediately see that angle dbc
angle dbc right over here
angle d
bc is going to be congruent to angle adb
to angle adb
angle a db for the exact same reason
they are alternate interior angles of a
transversal intersecting these two
parallel lines
so i could write this this is alternate
alternate interior
angles
interior angles are
congruent when you have a transversal
intersecting two parallel lines
and we also see that both of these
triangles triangle a d b
and triangle c d b both share this side
over here it's obviously equal to itself
now what is why is this useful
well you might realize that we've just
shown that both of these triangles they
have this pink angle then they have this
side in common and then they have the
green angle pink angle side in common
and then the green angle so we've just
shown by angle side angle that these two
triangles are congruent so let me write
this down we have shown that triangle
i'll go from non-labeled to pink to
green
a
d b
is congruent to triangle non-labeled to
pink to green
c
b d
b d and this comes out of angle side
angle congruency so this is from angle
side angle
angle side angle congruency well what
does that do for us well if two
triangles are congruent then all of the
corresponding features of the two
triangles are going to be congruent in
particular side dc
side dc corresponds to side ba on side
dc on this bottom triangle corresponds
to side ba on that top triangle so they
need to be congruent so dc
so we get dc
is going to be equal to
ba and that's because they are
corresponding sides corresponding sides
of
congruent congruent triangles so this is
going to be equal to that and by that
exact same logic a d
a d corresponds to c b
a d
corresponds to c b
a d is equal to cb and for the exact
same reason corresponding sides of
congruent triangles and then we're done
we've proven that opposite sides are
congruent now let's go the other way
let's go the other way let's say that we
have some type of a quadrilateral and we
know that the opposite sides are
congruent can we prove to ourselves that
this is a parallelogram well it's kind
of the same proof in reverse so let's
draw a diagonal here since we know a lot
about triangles
so let me draw
there we go
let me that's the hardest part let's see
draw it
that's pretty good all right so we
obviously know that cb is going to be
equal to itself
so i'll draw it like that we all
obviously because it's the same line and
then we have something interesting we've
split this quadrilateral into two
triangles triangle a c b
and triangle d b dbc and notice
they have all three sides of these two
triangles are equal to each other so we
know by side side side that they are
congruent so we know that triangle
triangle
a and we're starting a and then i'm
going to the
one hash side so a
c
a c b
is congruent to triangle d b c
d
bc and this is by
by side side side
side side side congruency well what does
that do for us well it tells us that all
of the corresponding angles are going to
be congruent
so for example abc
angle abc is going to be so let me
mark that
angle
a
b c
is going to be congruent and you can say
a b c is going to be congruent to dcb
dcb
angle d
cb
and you could say
by
you could say corresponding
angles
congruent
of
congruent triangles i'm just using some
shorthand here to save some time so abc
is going to be congruent to dcb so these
two angles are going to be congruent
well this is interesting because here
you have a line and it's intersecting a
b and c d and we clearly see that these
these things that could be alternate
angles alternate interior angles are
congruent and because we have these
congruent alternate interior angles we
know that a b must be parallel to cd
so this must be parallel to that so we
know that a b
is parallel to c d
by
alternate
alternate interior
angles
of of a transversal intersecting
parallel lines now we can use that exact
same logic we also know that angle let
me get this right angle acb
angle a c b
is congruent to angle dbc
to angle dbc
angle d
bc
and we know that by
corresponding
corresponding angles congruent of
congruent triangles
so we're just saying that this angle is
equal to that angle well once again
these could be alternate interior angles
they look like they could be this is a
transversal and here's two lines here
which we're not sure whether they're
parallel but because the alternate
interior angles are congruent we know
that they are parallel so this is
parallel to that so we know that ac
is parallel to bd
by alternate interior angles
by alternate
interior
angles and we're done so what we've done
is it's interesting we've shown
if you have a parallelogram opposite
sides are opposite sides have the same
length and if opposite sides have the
same length then you have a
parallelogram and so we've actually
proven it in both directions and so we
can actually make what you call an if
and only if statement you can say if
opposite sides are parallel of a
quadrilateral or you could say opposite
sides of quadrature are parallel if and
only if their lengths are equal and you
say if and only if so if they are
parallel then you could say their
lengths are equal and only if only if
their lengths are equal are they
parallel we've proven it in both
directions